remember that package you received when
you got into yl
well it's high time you receive another
since we cannot distribute the typical
items of the class day celebration
we've instead shipped every member of
our class a special class day care
package
the box includes many of the traditional
items the anthology that sarah told us
about yesterday
a yell college pin a handkerchief like
the one we received during our first
week at yale
though this time sponsored by the yale
alumni association
for bright college years this sunday
some of the traditional
items we are keeping for a future
in-person ceremony
such as the clay pipes that we
traditionally smashed together on old
campus
and don't worry we're going to get to do
that too the care package
also includes some special elements for
this year we've added the tassels that
would have come with your commencement
gown
as well as a special yale photo banner
whether you're wearing a suit and tie
or you're still wearing those pajamas
you put on in march
be sure to post a photo with the banner
and share it hashtag
yale2020 and now to the main attraction
of the day
the comedic reflection by simon fraser
je
and oscar lopez aguilera hopper we all
could use some laughs right now
and simon oscar sure can deliver so
here's to them
hey oscar
oh i think you're muted oh sorry dang it
um
is it am i good oh my
should we give this speech then the one
we wrote the day before spring break
that's the one uh do you think it'll be
an issue that some stuff
has happened since i don't see it
affecting our speech that much okay
let's do it correct
president salovey michelle obama
family friends uninvited cousin it is so
great
to be in new haven speaking to the
thousands of you
so close together the elm city the 06511
east of west haven west of east haven
unfair of fair haven
isn't it just a beautiful beautiful day
in sunny sunny new haven there's a
reason we endure
eight months of rain and snow and gloom
and improv shows for days like these
in new hampshire yeah simon sorry um i'm
actually seeing a problem with the
speech
uh what is it well our speech is ten
minutes and currently you spend six of
those talking about how nice it is to be
a new haven
what's your point well we're not
actually a new haven uh i am
i thought yale kicked us all out they
did but the old dean of pearson still
has a house here and she's letting me
stay
in exchange for a few favors what favor
just some yelp reviews oh
i'm just kidding i live off campus of
course you do what
nothing you know what should we just do
our more of today's speech fun that
sounds good
we are here to celebrate the class of
2020
what an iconic class not since the class
of 1010
and not until the class of 4 20 69
will there be a more iconic class year i
remember when i got accepted
early action legacy regular decision
poor and i was like i'm going to take a
gap year
and then i was like class of 20 21
okay simon really you you had a bodily
response to a classier
so immature they are just as special as
those
who came before us like the class of 20
[Music]
wait what's happening wait i'm scared
you try it class of 20
29 okay i think we gotta move on there
all right what in almost four years
we've had this year
the big celebration was yale 50. that's
right simon papa john continues to give
half off all pieces with the code yale
50.
what a deal no no oscar yale celebrated
50 years of
women being at the college which is
crazy
when you think about it because us guys
are only here for four
coming to yale was dancing before we
arrived on campus we didn't know so many
things
we didn't know if we were going to be
friends with our roommates we didn't
know what classes we were going to take
we didn't know if we were going to fit
in but we did know that even if
everything else
failed we would all have at least one
friend
george hey george how's it going
it's going well guys just eating
something that's enough george
in our four years we've have seen so
much and we have achieved
so much in our class we have road
scholars
and woad scholars we have finance bros
and astrology hubs i'm in the latter
varsity athletes who put their heart and
soul into their sports
we also have the rugby team we have
actors and writers
we have journalists and the ydn
we have cce instructors who taught us
about consent by having us
ask another person if they wanted to get
froyo since then only my foot group has
asked me to get froyo
you're gonna do fine that's the joke and
we have friends and acapella
groups who taught us about consent when
they said you really don't have to come
if you don't want to
and we did it we've had great inflation
no not as much as a model school in
cambridge
[Laughter]
we had feb club what a money-making sham
that was
i paid 29 to only go to the first party
which was at my house speaking of paying
for parties are we getting that 125
dollar senior dues refund
last time i checked making tick tocks
with free in our years at yale
we've had world-renowned scholars teach
us critical thinking
in all different fields and now most of
us will be applying those skills to make
the world of finance a better place
i however am actually using my critical
thinking to question why the lily pad is
on top of toads is the toad drowning
who's gonna save it yes i'm unemployed
but aren't we all
oscar it's not the lily pad it's
actually lily's pad
well who's lily is her name short for
lillian or liliana is that the toad's
name
it must be i took first order logic
while we were here
we won the game three out of four times
and the one time we lost was on a
baseball field now i may have just
learned that
a down isn't when a football player is
feeling sad but i'm pretty sure that
means it doesn't count
every touchdown was a home run during
this most recent game
a group of yale students united to
protest climate change and puerto rican
debt oscar
okay but i'm latinos this protest caused
some criticism
and the criticism went like this why
would these students decide to protest
the most
positive sporting events that would
maximize viewership and exposure
not only on campus but to alumni and
those watching the game across the
nation
and the answer still eludes me it just
makes no sense why would they do that
of course we also had the privilege walk
for those who don't remember
at the start of freshman year all the
frokos had a step forward
if we ever had some sort of privilege
and i don't know about you oscar
but for me what a workout
god they had me moving a lot have you
traveled to more than five countries
yes i have have you ever played tennis
let me step forwards
do you pronounce it finance i just did
wow i've never moved more yeah i know
right totally agree wait you moved too
yeah but they had me move backwards
there was psych in the good life yale's
biggest ever class
and the best part about that class was
that no one did
what they said they would do in their
final paper proposal
i said i was going to meditate for four
hours a day for two weeks
and then i sat down for like five
minutes and got bored and opened
instagram
uh what was that simon sorry you're
muted
i think i'm definitely not muted no you
are
then how did you know what i said sorry
wait
you know i didn't take second the good
life oh why is that
intro erm was at the same time so no
judgment but i guess we have different
definitions of self-care
we had the admissions scandal which
showed how getting into college isn't
always a meritocracy
but vice didn't interview me about it so
in a way i guess i'm richer than i
thought
kind of upper middle working class also
i want to take this time to say thank
you on behalf of myself
and all the other people who also never
sent a letter to their donors
so to my donor thank you
you're welcome of course coronavirus
came which has brought
so much unimaginable drama to an already
dramatic four years
coronavirus taught us a lot for me it
was learning just how many people go on
cruises
and for me it was just how seriously the
spring fling committee takes its job
when the world had already practically
stopped the campus was shut down for
good
and the cdc had banned gatherings of
more than 10 people
the spring fling committee sent out an
email saying they had tried
every option but have made the
incredibly tough
and not obvious at all decisions to
cancel spring fling
and i applaud that fear coronavirus
meant we also lost
out on a lot of things including senior
week
tonight would have been erotica which
for those who don't know
is one night when the entire senior
class goes to toad
wearing only underwear
oscar yeah sorry i think i got muted
i was trying to say that erotica
what is happening yeah
i don't think yale will let me describe
erotica
why not all it is is when 1 000 seniors
put on launch
they yeah they don't and they're
so big senior pj party there we go
oscar how are you dealing with the
effects of coronavirus in la
well i was trying to make the most of it
so i went to universal studios today but
they wouldn't let me in
that makes sense they were probably
closed because of the virus
yeah but i was like i don't think you
understand
i have a universal pass i lobbied the
yale administration for this i
emailed maybe u.s but they still
escorted me from the premises
and threatened to arrest me no oscar
universal pass was the policy adopted by
yale
where all grades became past fail but
that didn't mean our academic standards
slipped
uh simon i read an answer you wrote it
was terrible well that's not true
your opening line was emily dickinson
and paula neruda were two different
people some people have doubts about
that
it was your final paper for spanish your
point
you wrote it in english coronavirus also
meant that since people faced different
working conditions away from campus
some departments didn't award prizes for
senior theses
but what the university hasn't announced
yet is that because we were all apart
for these last few months
those big prizes the ones for the best
people at yale
they're gone too sorry suduri
i guess we'll never know if i was gonna
win the award for best community member
in branford college oscar you're in
hopper
i guess we'll never know no we're
kidding there will be the big prizes but
they don't always cover every category
therefore we have decided to do our own
prize giving
first up for most piggybacks and section
is everyone who took the s
then it's not sunny too often but for
the best tan
congratulations to saybrook's own tantan
wang
and finally a familiar face to the best
memer
george
we left yale too early and we had
different yale experiences
some of us never had the tuna tartar at
harvest and some of us still think
shades of yale is a facebook group
for overheard insults on campus
and it is all too easy to be engulfed in
the current moment
but for as many bad things as we've gone
through there have been so
many more good things we've shared late
lunches at commons
and we've shed late nights at butteries
we've shared photos on facebook and
we've shared study guides on google docs
we've shared seats at sold out dance
shows and we've shed utter contempt
for the other college and ims we've
shared franzia at parties and some of us
shared froyo in the sacks
and although yale was different for us
all and we all leave here having our own
personal connections to it
we all leave sharing one thing the
ugliest diploma
in america when you get it just look
just look at it and remind yourself of
the speech
so once this pandemic ends and the next
time you're in
new york or la or new york
and you see another person in the class
of 2020
maybe you'll wave to them like you did
your entire time at yale
after you met once in the zeta basement
but even if you don't you'll still know
that both of you share
being part of the most iconic class in
community at yale since 10
10 and still have so much more to share
here's the video